wir sind unterwegs oft über
Schotterpisten im Westen Kanadas in der
Provinzial Berta kanadisches Armageddon
nennen sie das was hier gerade passiert
große Teile der Provinz die von der
Fläche her nahezu zweimal so groß ist
wie Deutschland liegen und deiner
beißenden rauchdecke eine Qual für
Menschen aber auch für die vielen
Wildtiere die versuchen den Flammen zu
entkommen und nach neuen Lebensräumen
suchen müssen
über 500 Waldbrände hat es dieses Jahr
schon gegeben manche so groß wie Berlin
oder New York auf tief im Hinterland und
nur aus der Luft zu bekämpfen
im Bezirk yellow head treffen wir uns
mit dem Chef der Feuerwehr er sei ein
außergewöhnlich schlimmes Jahr erzählt
er uns
das sind die größten und schwersten
Feuer die wir in unserem Bezirk jemals
gesehen haben jemals
im Minutentakt nehmen die Löschflugzeuge
Wasser auf und werfen es über den
brennenden ab
überall in der Provinz bedrohen die
Feuer auch kritische Infrastruktur
die Einsatzkräfte von der schierengröße
der Brände überfordert allein hier im
Bezirk yellow hat kämpfen sie seit
Wochen gegen riesige Brände die
außerkontrolle geraten sind viele
Einwohner helfen mit und es bleibt die
noch nicht viel anderes übrig aber es
ist eine Sisyphusarbeit denn selbst wenn
die Flammen gelöscht sind brennen Torf
und Wurzeln bis zu einem Meter unter der
Erde weiter Monate manchmal jahrelang
du kannst dann einen Punkt kommen wo du
keine Glut und keinen Rauch mehr siehst
und zwei Tage später bricht das Feuer
dann wieder durch
viele Farben und Wohnhäuser in der
dünnen visiteten Provinz abgebrannt
immer wieder neu evakuierungsanordnungen
müssen Menschen ihre Häuser verlassen
finden Sie vorübergehend unter Schlupf
in Hotelzimmern die von der Gemeinde
angemietet sind Teresa Baumann und ihre
Enkel zeigen uns ein Video wie das Feuer
ihre Farben immer näher kam
[Musik]
um 8.9 kam die Nachricht dass wir
evakuieren müssen denn das shining Feuer
kamen unsere Richtung Luftlinie ungefähr
12 Kilometer
als der Wind heute gedreht hat haben sie
gesagt wir müssen weg ich habe alles in
den Pferdeanhänger gepackt und dann sind
wir los
für die die bleiben und die Feuer
bekämpfen ist nicht nur das Feuer selbst
eine Gefahr auch die Bewohner des Waldes
können ihn immer wieder gefährlich
werden
ich habe Angst vor Bären ich glaube alle
draußen haben Angst vor Bären die Bären
haben mehr Angst vor dem Feuer als vor
uns wir haben beobachtet wie Tiere aus
den brennenden Gebieten herausrennen
also Bären Hirsche Kaninchen sie sind
alle gerannt sie versuchen auch zu
überleben wir auch wir haben Maßnahmen
ergriffen Bären mögen keine
Menschenmassen also arbeiten wir in
Gruppen
auf unseren oft stundenlangen Fahrten
durch die Einsamkeit geht uns durch den
Kopf wie wir damit umgehen würden wenn
unser Wagen eine Panne hat ein Reifen
auf der raumpiste platzt mitten in der
Wildnis zwischen immer wieder
aufflammenden feuern und der Gefahr das
dann plötzlich ein Bär aus dem Wald
hervorbricht
fünf Stunden geht es für uns Richtung
Süden nach Nordeck wir haben uns mit
einem verabredet der weiß was zu tun ist
wenn sich Mensch und Bär in der Wildnis
begegnen
y ist wenn man so will der
bärenflüsterer kann da sein Job ist
dafür zu sorgen dass ich Mensch und Bär
nicht allzu nahe kommen und wenn doch
dass sie Begegnungen nicht tödlich enden
für beide Seiten
wir sind mit ihm unterwegs auf einem
viele Hektar großen Privatgrundstück der
Besitzer hatte den vergangenen Tagen
stark gewildaktivität gemeldet Wölfe und
Bären aufgenommen mit sogenannten
Wildkameras
die Waldbrände würden allen zu schaffen
machen besonders aber den Bären
[Musik]
weekend hell wir spüren schon wie
schlimm es wirklich stinkt einige
bekommen Kopfschmerzen anderen tränen
die Augen und du hast hier ein Tier
dessen gesamte Überlebensinstinkt in
seiner Nase liegt
wenn also Waldbrände die ganze Provinz
wie jetzt einhüllen ist die gesamte
Tierwelt gestört und fühlt sich unwohl
die Tiere geraten in den Normen Stress
fliegen vor dem Feuer oft kreuzen sich
dann die Wege mit den Menschen
darüber nach wo wir unsere Bemühungen
einsetzen um die Brände zu stoppen
hauptsächlich rund um Dörfer und
Gemeinden und so weiter also wenn du
eine Pufferzone zwischen dem Brandgebiet
und der Gemeinde hast werden sich dort
alle Tiere ansammeln
so Ryan will uns zeigen worauf wir
achten müssen wenn wir in den Wäldern
unterwegs sind und was wir unbedingt
immer mit dabei haben sollten Beeren
Spray
wenn der Bär auf dich zukommt fängst du
unten bei den Füßen an zu sprühen und
arbeitest dich bis zur Nase hoch du
erzeugst einen gleichmäßigen Nebel der
Bär wird in diese Wolke Rennen und dann
abhauen
wenn es um Leben und Tod geht ist das
egal oder am Ende geht es darum den
Bären zu stoppen wenn du dabei ein
bisschen Husten musst dann ist es halt
so es geht uns überleben
im Wald zeigt er uns dann woran wir
kennen können ob Bären in der Nähe sind
oder zumindest waren
Fährten und kurze dabei das
offensichtlichste
worauf wir aber niemals geachtet hätten
sind Bäume mit abgerissenen Zweigen
rubbel Bäume an denen sich die Bären
kratzen Ryan macht es uns vor
und dann zupfte ein paar Haare aus dem
Geäst eindeutig Grizzly meinte
es ist christlich und wenn du genauer
hinschaust wird es dunkler je weiter du
zu den Enden kommst das ist dieser
grizzly-look
hätten wir den Baum nicht beachtet wären
wir an ihm achtlos vorbei gelaufen jetzt
wo wir wissen dass wir uns in einem
aktiven Grizzly Revier befinden wird uns
doch ein bisschen mulmig
ein paar hundert Meter weiter auf einer
Lichtung Knochen von Hirschen und Elchen
und auch im Wald überall Überreste von
Tieren die der bergerissen hat zu
unserer Erleichterung wohl schon etwas
älter genau sie wissen dass das sie eine
gute jagdzone ist also kommen Sie immer
wieder zurück bei Bären geht alles um
Belohnungen wenn Sie in einem Gebiet
belohnt werden wird es Teil ihrer
Routine und deshalb ist es so wichtig
wenn wir über menschliche
Anziehungspunkte sprechen an einen Ort
an dem er belohnt wird kommt er zurück
ein Ort also an dem die Bären immer
wieder zurückkehren weil sie hier
leichte Beute haben nicht unbedingt ein
Information die uns beruhigt wir aber
sollten wir sollte man reagieren wenn
plötzlich ein Grizzly auftaucht der Bär
nutzt den Weg genauso wie wir wenn wir
also in eine dieser Kahlschläge fahren
wirst du sehen wie ein Bär einfach daran
vorbei geht wenn der Bär jedoch einen
anderen Weg nimmt und sich dir nähert
dann hast du etwas mehr zu befürchten es
gibt Neugierde Raubtier Verhalten und
ähnliches das ist der Moment in dem du
aufspringen musst du musst bereit sein
mach Lärm wenn der Bär trotzdem auf dich
zukommt dann ist das ein Kampf auf Leben
und Tod aber in Situationen in denen du
einfach einen Bären auf einem Weg
begegnest bleib ruhig und entferne dich
langsam von ihm
fast einen ganzen Tag sind wir mit Ryan
unterwegs ein Grizzly aber sehen wir
nicht und wir sind eigentlich auch ganz
froh darüber Ryan schickt uns zwei Tage
später ein Video dass er kurz nach
unserem Besuch aufgenommen hat eine
Grizzlybären mit zwei jungen ein
kanadisches Idyll so wirkt es auf den
ersten Blick bis die Bärenmutter sich
für Angriff entscheidet
[Applaus]
die Begegnung geht für beide glücklich
aus erzählt uns Ryan später und wir sind
froh dass wir jetzt wissen worauf wir
achten müssen auf unserem Weg durch die
Weiten Kanadas wo in diesen Wochen auf
saftiges Grün immer wieder Wälder folgen
die den Flammen zum Opfer gefallen sind
in manchen Wäldern hat es so lange und
heiß gebrannt dass sie praktisch
biologisch tot sind dass sie sich aus
eigener Kraft mittelfristig nicht mehr
regenerieren können weil alles Leben in
den Böden erloschen ist alle Samen
verbrannt
etwa sechs Milliarden Bäume sind bislang
den Flammen zum Opfer gefallen so die
Schätzungen eine Katastrophe auch für
das Klima wenn diese Bäume nicht schnell
wieder nachwachsen
in Toronto 3000 Kilometer weiter östlich
treffen wir uns mit Angelique Arts
Stream und price Jones sie haben sich
entschieden vor der sich anbahnen den
Katastrophen nicht zu resignieren
sondern die Dinge selbst in die Hand zu
nehmen
du kennst die Zahlen das ist doch alles
sehr beängstigend wir haben nur noch ein
kleines Zeitfenster um das Problem zu
lösen
wir haben keine Zeit mehr auf politische
Entscheidungen zu warten um CO2-neutral
zu werden das dauert alles viel zu lang
wir müssen jetzt
Handelns Flash forest eine Milliarde
Bäume wollen sie allein in Kanada bis
2028 Pflanzen und denkbar mit
herkömmlichen Methoden
ich selbst habe früher mit der Hand
gepflanzt 76.000 Bäume es gab keinerlei
Automatisierung alles war ganz einfach
du hast Leute im Feld die haben eine
Schaufel und einen großen Sack mit Samen
alles hat dabei die Produktivität war so
nicht zu steigern
bei Flash forest Arbeiten Luft und
Raumfahrt Ingenieure Mathematikerin
Computer Bio und Agrarwissenschaftler
alle zwischen Anfang 20 und Mitte 30 sie
alle arbeiten an einem Plan zur
Revolutionierung der wieder
im Wesentlichen versuchen wir
Performance und machine learning zu
optimieren wir können so Daten sammeln
wofür Menschen ein Vielfaches an Zeit
bräuchten wir haben alle Geräte dafür
kommerzielle Drohnen großartige
Technologien und die Macht von
künstlicher Intelligenz um die Welt
besser zu machen
in Echtzeit verfolgen sie die Brände und
deren Intensität nutzen Satelliten Daten
um Hitzeentwicklung Bodenbeschaffenheit
und Topographie zu kartieren wir nutzen
machine learning auch um Hindernisse und
Strukturen wie Bäume und Wege
aufzuspüren so können wir Einsatzorte
genau vermessen und dann wie hier
Hindernisse ausschließen und ganz genau
festlegen wo wir Pflanzen müssen
mit diesen Daten werden Drohnen
gefüttert die dann selbstständig
speziell entwickelte nährstoffkapseln
mit enthaltenen Samen an exakt
vordefinierten Orten platzieren
Schwerpunkte aus Toronto sind die großen
waldbrandgebiete in Kanadas Westen
innerhalb Wörter und britisch Columbia
Orte die für die manuelle Aufforstung
kaum zugänglich sind tief im Hinterland
oft müssen Schneisen in den Wald
geschlagen repariert werden um das
Equipment an den richtigen Ort zu
bringen
Knochenarbeit die dazugehört Mackenzie
ist gerade 23 geworden ist zuständig für
Transport die Einweisung in die richtige
Handhabung der Geländefahrzeuge und wir
sagen wir mal Straßenbau
das ist wirklich harte Arbeit die
Operation am Laufen zu halten besonders
das hoch und runterfahren mit den
Hängern die Schlingern und wenn sie
irgendwo hängen bleiben können sie dich
aus der Spur reißen
und wir verstehen was sie meint als wir
mit unserer Kamera Ausrüstung tief in
den Wald den Berg hinauf zum Start und
Landeplatz der Drogen gebracht werden
oben auf der Operationsbasis sind sie
dabei die rund 120.000 Dollar teuren
Drohnen mit den Samen Hülsen zu befüllen
etwa 80 Kilo davon kann eine Drohne
tragen
7 Minuten Takt starten und landen die
Riesen Maschinen mit einer Spannweite
von mehr als 3 m
und der Bodenstation überwacht um im
Notfall manuell eingreifen zu können
ansonsten ziehen sie völlig autark ihre
Bahnen über das unzugängliche Gelände
wir haben im Moment eine Reichweite von
5 km wir haben so Zugang zu Bereichen
die man sonst nur sehr schwer erreichen
kann oder die zu gefährlich sind für
Menschen denn die verbrannten Bäume
können durch einen Windstoß jederzeit
Umstürzen
alle die hier monatelang Arbeiten
zwischen Milliarden Mücken und Bremsen
sind hochqualifizierte Experten könnten
jederzeit ein gut bezahlten Job in einem
großen Unternehmen bekommen und doch
haben Sie sich für das unbequeme Leben
im Wald entschieden
abends im Camp 40 Minuten weiter unten
im Tal zeigen sie uns womit sie jeden
Tag so zu kämpfen haben und wir fragen
uns warum sie sich das alles antun
[Gelächter]
du hast das Gefühl etwas Sinnvolles für
die Umwelt zu tun um eine bessere Welt
für die nächsten Generationen zu
schaffen hoffentlich ja ich liebe es
werden sich die einen abends am
Lagerfeuer entspannen macht sich eine
andere Crew schon wieder auf um die
Drohnen für die nächsten Morgen
vorzubereiten gleich beim ersten
Tageslicht wieder fliegen zu können
das Gewehr immer mit dabei und das hat
einen Grund
wir passen auf das kein Bär an unseren
Drohnen rumkaut
da gibt es Bären
da gibt es viele Bären viele Bären und
Elche Grizzlys und Schwarzbären
und habt ihr Angst vor den Bären
ich nicht aber es gibt ja schon ein paar
die darauf Wert legen gut beschützt zu
sein
in dieser Nacht schauen die Bären nicht
vorbei und so können sie am nächsten
Morgen die Drohnen wieder fliegen 25
Millionen Bäume wollen sie so diese
Saison Pflanzen 60 Millionen dann im
nächsten Jahr aufgeben wollen sie nicht
auch wenn die Herausforderungen immer
größer wird denn Feuersbrünste wie in
diesem Jahr hat Kanada noch nie erlebt